on tv
on radio and on your smartphone this is
talk tv
[Music]
tonight on piers morgan uncensored with
me jeremy kyle rocketing rents and
mortgage madness where and how to live
in a cost of living crisis blowtorch
britain faces blazes in yet another
heatwave rr firefighters in danger of
burning out plus former us national
security adviser john bolton on his old
boss donald trump and surviving an
assassination attempt by iran
[Music]
[Music]
good evening my friends and a big
welcome to piers morgan uncensored with
me jeremy kyle first tonight though very
importantly and very rare a missing
person's appeal we don't normally do
this on uncensored but authorities my
friends are urgently seeking information
which may help them locate the leader of
the british opposition zakir starmer is
described as pale stale a white male who
is apparently five foot eight inches
tall his closest allies i'm looking for
him describes him as extremely boring
his hobbies include having a curry and a
pint but only at business meetings and
whilst his labour party colleagues once
infinitely said never waste a good
crisis care at this moment of utmost
strife and in the total absence of a
functioning government the opposition
and this man are nowhere to be seen now
if you have any information i implore
you this is massively important secures
whereabouts matter to the nation
shape it is but you can tweet me at j
kyle official anything for an extra you
know no rewards the budget was spent on
this honestly useless they used to call
this man captain hindsight judging by
what you're about to see i reckon when
he gets back if he gets back if we ever
find him again they'll call him captain
hypocrite
i want to see these issues resolved and
my criticism is really of the government
because um it's inevitable i think when
you've got a cost of living crisis
that so many working people are
concerned about their wages i understand
that i understand the concerns the role
of government is to do something
the role of government is to do
something and the role of the opposition
is to give a creditable alternative so
sakia the labour party in general where
are you why would we vote for you give
us a reason if you see him at j kyle
official we want to find sakia stammer
right first tonight our series on the
cost of living crisis continues tonight
we thought we'd concentrate on the
housing market now the situation is so
bad this is true you can now apparently
buy a whole scottish island with its own
lighthouse
and a helipad for less than two-thirds
of the average london house price check
this out this is plada island it's a
private island which has just gone on
the market for
350 grand it's about 30 miles from
glasgow and features not only a
five-bedroom house but the entire 30
acres of land surrounding it although
the current lighthouse keeper did tell
us it does need a bit of an update
apparently it's worth it and listen at
the end of the day i i might think this
show might buy and put uh put nicola
sturgeon at the top uh listen joining me
once again financial expert gemma
godfrey how are you good thank you and
also star of homes under the hammer and
my martin roberts good evening how are
you sir
good evening i'm very good sir i want to
be on the island
what with nicholas sturgeon are on your
own
yeah we'll pass on that one um both of
you welcome but let's just talk gemma
firstly uh
rates are rising mortgages are more
expensive
there are so many problems in the
housing market i might just say and i'm
being completely honest uh tobias
alexander an estate agent was booked to
be here tonight next to you
unfortunately didn't make it apparently
he tried to get a train but there were
no drivers he tried to take his car but
he couldn't find any petrol and it
literally all went horrendously wrong so
you're on your own but we've got martin
um
if you've got a mortgage right now
what's the best thing if you've come out
of a fixed-rate mortgage if you look at
everything that's going on the bills
that are on the way what's the correct
way to behave gemma i mean i think this
is a real challenge because a lot of
people like fixed rate mortgages because
it gives you the peace of mind to know
how much you're going to be paying every
month you're able to budget for it
you're able to sleep well at night but
the problem is you pay a premium and
banks aren't stupid so they're pricing
in further rate rises and some people
prefer to spend less money now because
things are so dire so you've got you've
got um fixed rate you've got variable
rate the important thing as well is when
are you thinking of moving house there
are lots of different variables that are
important to take into account but
ultimately you've got two million that
are already on mortgages that are going
up in price you've got two million where
their fixed rate is going to end in a
year yeah first rate buyers and
first-time buyers are also finding it
hard to get onto the property
let's pick that up first time i was just
bringing martin um you know homes under
the hammer host you know more about
property than than anybody but there is
an argument martin right now that it's
almost impossible to get on that
property ladder and more and more people
are turning their back on trying to even
attempt to get a mortgage and renting
property and in terms of this financial
crisis one then wonders what landlords
are going to do are they going to
swallow these increases how difficult is
it for people to get on that property
ladder buddy
well i mean there are always ways jeremy
and i just trying to advise people to
just like think outside the box it's
always been tough you know i remember
trying to save for my first property and
and relatively it was expensive for me
but
you have to think a bit more
laterally about how you're going to
achieve this maybe
not exactly going for your first choice
of location somewhere uh a cheaper
property because there are still
bargains to be had in the uk i mean you
can still get houses you know a
reasonable two-bedroom terraced house
for like 80 90 000 pounds and one thing
you've got when you're a first-time
buyer is enthusiasm and and time so
start building in that that equity into
your first property and don't think well
you know i want to live in kensington i
need to buy in kensington let's think
well i'll get there eventually but i'll
go via a series of routes where i'm
going to buy myself something a bit more
affordable i think the problem is for
many people when you think about you
know the utility bills electricity gas
4200 from 1 200 little over a year the
price of petrol everything seems to be
going up and i just wondered from your
point of view what is driving up the
cost of housing i know you're big on you
know the government said they built 300
000 more homes that hasn't happened do
we need to build more to make it more
affordable martin
absolutely because that is the reality
there isn't enough property available
and in any kind of economy or any kind
of economic environment
if there's a a rarity of a product that
product then obviously goes up in value
the numbers of houses that are for sale
is just a tiny fraction of what it what
it was and i think most people's
experience is if you go to buy a house
before you've even had a chance to see
it somebody will have bought it it's
really scary but that does not create a
buyer's market that creates a seller's
market it is really really tough i get
that um i think it's worth persevering
though because as you've already said
landlords are struggling too they're
seeing increasing in their bills they're
seeing things they can't uh mitigate
against taxes and all that sort of thing
so rents are naturally going to go up
and you've seen that so i still think
it's worth doing whatever you can to get
yourself on that market and what i say
to people is don't give up hope because
there are ways of achieving it if you're
shouting at the television now going
yeah it's all right for him to say that
honestly there are ways you can do it do
not give up hope completely agree gemma
what about some tips i mean how can you
make your house more attractive to a
seller martin's right it's a it's a
ridiculous market it has been it's it's
peaked it's probably going to start down
i want to know what you would say to
people who are thinking i want to get my
household to move on up the ladder but i
just can't what can we do i mean
obviously things like you know improving
how attractive it is when people first
walk in i mean the old cliche of you
know cooking bread or whatever but it
does you know it's those simple little
things i think that can help set a house
but what's really interesting is that
there are also things that you can do to
try and help build up a deposit for your
next home as well while you're while
you're in a house so for example things
like renting out your driveway is quite
a good way to make money there's also
renting out a spare room or obviously
the whole house when you go on holiday
and all these little things can really
help people and there are also for
people to get onto the ladder in the
first place um you know help to buy
schemes and there's also lysis which is
lifetime isis where the government gives
you a little bit of money as well every
time you save a certain amount so there
are schemes out there to try and help
but ultimately you know trying to help
find your dream home it can take one or
two or three different steps brilliant
martin you you were nodding your head
what sort of tips would you give to
people watching this tonight
well in terms of selling one of the the
simplest things i've i've come across is
i
the creation of like a little pack of
information for somebody coming to your
house what was it about the house that
you really loved that made you buy it
what are the local amenities you know
when you go to a hotel there's like a
pack of information if you are looking
to sell quickly and i think it's not too
difficult at the moment but an
information pack you could give people
but in terms of of of thinking how else
you can maybe get on the ladder what
about um linking up with um relatives
who've maybe got money in the bank and
saying to them i'll tell you what why
don't i cut you in on a bit of a deal
i've got the energy i've got the
enthusiasm i'm going to find a property
i'm going to do it up we can share the
profit if you help me buy that property
and then you start building your own
equity so you might find people out
there who are still getting diddly squat
in terms of their savings who would buy
into that plan as long as it's all
written down as long as everyone
understands what's uh what's in it for
everybody that can be a really good way
to do it or just link up with friends
and again as long as it's sorted out
between you and it's written down
exactly what the deal is you can
actually do a joint purchase with
somebody and that could be another way
just to get you started you know
you don't have to get your ideal
solution right at the beginning really
interesting um gemma just i was reading
a statistic today uh britain is ranked
so low in home ownership in the 35
european countries really really low
down um
would you buy a house would you i know
what martin's saying try and get on that
ladder would you buy a house right now
would you rent my fear for landlords is
that landlords are going to say right
well those electricity bills are going
to go up and all of that i'm going to
you know hike that rent many people
watching this tonight are going to be
saying that's all well and good but we
haven't got the ability to save we
haven't even got the ability to pay the
bills that are in front of us we need
help should the government be doing more
to kick-start their state you know the
the business of buying and selling
houses there needs to be more affordable
housing that's the problem is that
actually one in five they did a research
recently one in five people are renting
for five or even nine years before they
can even get onto the property ladder so
obviously more does need to be done to
be able to help support more people
getting um into home ownership
do you think one of the problems is that
buying i mean i noticed the other day
they banned mortgages for for buy to
rent right which it strikes me that
there aren't enough houses and also a
lot of people have more than one so
that's another reason why there aren't
enough to go around the mortgage
companies have stopped doing that
because of course there's no money do
you think that will help people but also
if you think about what the cost of
living crisis is doing it's putting up
prices everywhere so it's not just
mortgages if we look at rents rents are
over nine and a half percent it's almost
10 higher than they were a year ago so
it's becoming painful on all fronts so
actually a lot of people ask me oh there
may be a housing price correction coming
should i just wait a bit the problem
about waiting is you're eroding all your
money on rent if you're lucky enough to
be able to be saving towards a property
um and if you again if you want to get
on the property ladder timing the market
is so incredibly hard and some people
don't have that luxury they just have to
wait and try and save as much they can
it's been brilliant having you on all
week you won breakfast with me tomorrow
we're getting depressed but we're trying
to be completely honest uh martin
roberts thank you very much indeed gemma
godfrey as well financial expert more
cost of living crisis next week but
nexon uncensored prices are soaring
we've said that the nhs is in crisis in
many people's minds the uk is going up
in smoke but the opposition nowhere to
be seen the government's in self-imposed
exile what the hell are we going to do
it's time my friends to phone a friend
john cordwell founder of phones for you
is live after this break don't go away
i'm coming back in three
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
thank you my friends welcome back to
uncensored here's a question what does
it take to lead in a crisis well there's
different approaches you can fight them
on the beaches of course or like the
british government you can fight them
from the beaches you can roll up your
sleeves and face the music or like the
bystander in chief you can get lost in
your sleeves and ultimately face the
tarmac
some of the great crisis leaders make
the big decisions without skipping a
beat
hours well he went skipping
liz trust meanwhile is busy worrying
about the cover of vogue apparently
sunak just covering the hole in his
brogues and as britain prepares to
officially declare a drought tomorrow
surely both of them are deeply concerned
about how they'll water their magic
money trees today's government meeting
with energy bosses i have to tell you
achieved absolutely nothing kirsten's
plan is as clear as the sundial in the
fog this entire country is going to hell
in a handcart but to give our leaders
some credit i'm told tonight exclusively
they are all giving 110
sadly my friends that's probably the
inflation rate next january so we
decided with a crisis of leadership to
go with our cost of living crisis a
drought crisis and energy crisis and
every other crisis we need a leader we
need a guy who's got some ideas and i'm
delighted to be joined by phones for you
founder and billionaire british business
luminary you try saying that john kohler
how are you my friend
well much better after that introduction
jeremy thank you
john we know each other well we have a
heat wave we have a cost of living
crisis we have the nhs on its knees the
parliament's out of action our leaders
are nowhere to be seen
you founded one of the most successful
businesses this country has ever seen
are you impressed by the the politicians
work ethic right now
well i'm not impressed by the
politicians generally in the performance
of the last two years but
often
the performance is lacking regardless of
which party's in and regardless of which
period you're talking about you know
there was so much could have been done
in the last two and a half years by the
conservative government and it hasn't
been done
and that is such a disastrous loss to
society so no i'm i'm not particularly
happy at all jeremy you uh famously
donated half a million quid to the
tourist before the last election one of
their chief donors um
did you expect more in return would you
be doing it again where are you at with
that
well it was a one-off donation and it
was really to help keep corbin and
mcdonnell out and
am i happy with that yes absolutely
because i think they would have been a
fiasco for britain um having said which
the combination of brexit ukraine war
um
energy crisis drought crisis we're not
in a very good place are we and so
but this is so much more could have been
done by an ambitious government
um i find myself frustrated um i don't
know if you share that frustration you
know johnson got that
that mandate yeah i mean we'd be the
same and and and it seems to have
disappeared with with this minou shy of
ridiculous decisions you were very
critical of russia's sunax furlough
scheme i remember at the time he said it
was it was too dangerous and it would
fuel inflation there we go john cole
were right russia soon that wrong um is
he to blame and where do you stand on
this this party leadership campaign john
well absolutely is to blame i mean only
for part of it of course because the
the ukraine situation and the energy
crisis is a big part of it as well
but you know rishi could have done so
much more i went out two and a half
years ago immediately the pandemic
struck and said nobody should be
substantially worse off as a result of
the pandemic well unfortunately it made
people better off as a result of the
pandemic
and of course there was then a
de-stocking of the entire supply chain
throughout the world
so as soon as people then came back to
the market post-pandemic there was a
huge desire and demand for goods that
had not been uh produced over the
previous two years and that really has
stoked inflation
but also in addition he neglected three
or four million i don't know how many of
the three or four million that are
so-called forgotten or so-called
excluded but he certainly neglected some
of them and made them substantially
worse off
so he got a lot of things wrong
and i am of course naturally quite
critical of that because being being
very patriotic for a bit and i want to
see britain prosper and succeed i don't
want governments making big mistakes
that are
avoidable
um one of the things that
just causes so much anger amongst our
viewers and our listeners is every week
there seems to be another story john
about an energy firm with billions of
pounds worth of profits and you know
bills i think from this year one the
average electricity 1277 it's 4 200
pounds by next generation i cannot over
exaggerate this enough there will be
millions of people in this country who
cannot pay their bills out of the blue
today we hear the energy bosses met with
the government boris turned up uh
windfall taxes were ruled out apparently
the meeting ended with no agreement as a
businessman a successful business unless
i'm missing the point you need to keep
your customers happy do you not think
that the government should put pressure
on these energy firms to give some of
those ridiculously large profits back to
the very people the consumers that have
them where they are
i do absolutely but there is a very very
difficult dilemma here because i was a
great advocate of windfall taxis on
those companies during the pandemic that
benefited enormously
out of
um the fact that all the shops were
short and everybody's driven online
i would also be an advocate of uh taking
some of the energy companies profits off
them as well but and this is a really
big but
britain has to be seen to be a
friendly
country
towards businesses that are coming into
our country because if we are seen to
just keep taking money from people who
have win for profits it'll make us much
less desirable to be invested upon so i
don't actually have the answer for that
but
i do think there is a cause to win for
taxis i do think they could be
implemented as a one-off uh as long as a
guarantee was given then that that same
type of tax wouldn't occur in the future
years maybe a decade or so
because you've got to give people
confidence that they can build a
business in britain without suddenly
losing profitability but at the same
time they paid a fortune i get that one
final question and it is always a
pleasure to pick the brains of somebody
i mean you should be prime minister
tomorrow because you'd turn up you're
one of the biggest single taxpayers in
this country i want you
um because you are a self-made man i
want you to address the men and women of
this country watching talk right now and
saying he's a billionaire i'm being
straight um uh kyle's on the telly i am
struggling i'm a jam just about managing
i've got two kids i literally have got a
few quid left at the end of the week
when i've played this that and the other
i'm not getting any handouts i'm not
getting anything i see this every single
day energy petrol food i'm really at the
end of my tether what message john paul
what would you give and this is the sort
of message that the government should
give what would you say
well i i think the government really do
have to help the people at the very
bottom of the food chain and help them
substantially we should potentially be
looking at minimum wages in this country
and whether to implement a new minimum
wage but certainly as an emergency
measure we should be helping out
dramatically with the energy crisis but
i think we will do that but we shouldn't
be giving it to everybody because a lot
of people can afford it and it is a real
cost so we should be giving it to those
people that really cannot afford to pay
their way and are really going to
struggle and i think the government will
do that at least i really hope so john
cole well um that's what i call real
leadership they're talking and giving
practical advice we really appreciate
you joining us tonight thank you very
much indeed really appreciate that where
are our politicians nowhere to be seen
john caldwell on the television saying
this is what i do thank you my friend
right my next guest is lucky to be alive
well he had a price on his head
300 000 to be precise yes this week an
iranian man was charged by the united
states with plotting to kill former
president trump's national security
adviser the ploy is thought to have been
retaliation for the killing of
revolutionary guard commander qasim
solamani by the us military in 2020 the
iranians say no no these allegations are
basis baseless the target was former u.s
national security adviser john bolton
he's very much alive and kicking which
is the delightful piece of information
and he joins me now john welcome to
uncensored thank you very much indeed
glad to be with you um
there's a reason i i love i love the
fact that when we were doing the
research today and i was like oh my
goodness me we're going to be talking to
trump's ex
they said the first thing you've got to
ask him is apparently he's really
annoyed that the bounty on his head was
only three hundred thousand dollars is
that right sir
sure i mean i i i would have thought
would have hoped that uh for all the
trouble that caused iran it would have
been higher but
maybe they're in deeper economic trouble
than we thought
uh on a serious note why would iran want
to kill you john bolton
well it's a terrorist regime and uh it's
not me alone there are many other
former government officials that have
been targeted
and not only former government officials
an iranian-american an american citizen
now in brooklyn new york was the subject
of what was unquestionably an attack
about 10 days or two weeks ago because
she was writing critically of the
government of iran for its policy on
women
so the this is this is uh not a state
sponsor of terror this is a state
terrorist government uh and it's uh
unprecedented in its reach it has
carried out terrorist uh operations in
the middle east in europe uh but now
trying to kill americans on american
soil
john um
in the west we've seen what's happened
in ukraine we've been told by our
leaders that we can't put feet on the
ground in ukraine and with europe we've
instigated far-reaching sanctions but we
still watch every day appalling footage
of putin's tanks and soldiers killing
defenseless people across ukraine we
marvel at ukraine's strength of
character like your opinion on your
current president um
is is biden weak is the western biden
weak in russia in your opinion should we
should we be doing more to get to get
putin out to to lay down a marker
yeah look we are not doing as well as
people think our biggest failure
occurred in february when we did not
deter the russians from invading can
talk as we should about the bravery and
the competence of the ukrainians
fighting back but let's be clear the
west as a whole failed to deter putin
and that that was the greatest mistake
we made right now we're in a race
uh as nato weapons u.s and uk weapons in
particular get to the ukrainian front
lines uh they're able to use them
effectively in combat but as of the
moment the other side of this race the
russians are still gaining ground and in
a war about territory they are winning
let's be clear they've paid huge costs
they are winning and the question is
whether putin seizes the diplomatic
initiative uh in a way that catches
europe and the united states unaware and
allows him to consolidate his
territorial gains
um
over here i have to say this side of the
pond biden's presidency was was met with
real optimism two years ago and is now
with the greatest of respect laughed at
i want to bring you a quick update
because this is justin on the reason we
just had this released uh behind the
search of president trump's florida home
the other day u.s attorney general
merrick confirmed that fed searched
trump's florida estate to establish
whether he illegally removed records
from the white house
as he was leaving office
first
i personally approve the decision to
seek a search warrant in this matter
second the department does not take such
decision lightly
where possible it is standard practice
to seek less intrusive means as an
alternative to a search and to narrowly
scope any search that is undertaken
third
let me address recent unfounded attacks
on the professionalism of the fbi and
justice department agents and
prosecutors
i will not stand by silently when their
integrity is unfairly attacked
john barton had jason miller an ex-trump
aide on this show on monday and he said
that the democrats and really the
establishment in its entirety in
washington will stop at nothing to
prevent donald trump from standing again
and potentially holding public office
whether it's his tax affairs whether
it's allegations of stuff you know
documentation he removed we had him
invoking the fifth amendment and
refusing to answer questions in new york
on wednesday what is your take on your
your ex-boss do you think that these
these allegations are founded in truth
or do you think it's a witch hunt
well i don't think it's a witch hunt i
think there's much we don't know you
know the tradition in the united states
as it is in great britain is that
criminal investigations and prosecutions
are carried on in silence in private the
department of justice in our case
doesn't give a running commentary on
what it finds uh so so when a party to
to a criminal proceeding like this a
potential criminal proceeding speaks out
uh the natural inclination of the
department of justice is to say nothing
i think that's a mistake and i'm very
glad that the attorney general did speak
out today i'm an alumnus of the
department of justice myself it's a
great honor to work there it has good
people and bad people like every human
institution but the idea that it's
fundamentally corrupt that it's
fundamentally controlled by any
political party
and is directed against any political
figure fundamentally wrong and anybody
who tells you to the contrary simply is
ignorant that's it period close quote
the better thing to do here would be for
all of us to hold silent until we know
more now merrick garland has done a very
interesting thing
uh he is filed with the court
uh which approved this search warrant
wasn't the department of justice frolic
on its own a court approved this search
warrant he's asked that it all be
unsealed
um
john two very very quick questions to
finish i'd love to have more time uh
first one would the world be safer if
president trump became the president
again and do you think he'll declare for
2024
no the world would not be safer because
donald trump doesn't have a philosophy
is uh living working in his white house
is like living inside a pinball machine
that's not what you need to guarantee
american and western security uh my own
view at least before the search warrant
uh earlier this week was that he would
not run in 2024 he knows he lost in 2020
he fears losing again he hates being
called a loser worse than anything else
he would talk about running incessantly
but when the rubber met the road he
would not run whether this week's events
have changed that or not i don't know i
still don't think he'll run as of now
john belton an absolute pleasure to
speak to you thank you for joining us
tonight from america john bolton there
on uncensored uh next it's a tinderbox
out there that's a that's an absolute
fact fire chiefs are warning all of us
of an unprecedented danger of wildfires
this weekend i want to know how real is
that risk i also want to know what we
can do about it we'll talk to a fire
brigade union leader and a firefighter
nexon and censor we're coming right back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
this is talk tv
[Music]
welcome back now we used to say that
britain basks in glorious sunshine now
it's fair to say that britain burns
wildfire season has long been a summer
peril in southern europe in california
in australia but is it now becoming a
grim reality for the united kingdom on
tuesday the medoff has issued an amber
warning for extreme heat this weekend
with temperatures expected to hit 36
degrees celsius experts tell us that
tinderbox conditions have created a risk
of exceptional fire severity across
large swathes of this country now this
august heat wave hot on the heels of the
driest july since 1935 has drained
reservoirs rivers and lakes and millions
of people in the south of england could
be under a hosepipe ban in the coming
weeks part of the country are also
expected to tonight be declared as
officially in a drought delighted to be
joined now by andy dark assistant
general secretary from the fire brigades
union and firefighter stuart gillen from
dorset and wiltshire fire and rescue i'd
like to start with you andy
um we don't want to scare people but we
want to be
realistic
how dangerous is it right now in the
united kingdom and what should people be
doing to help your service i think uh i
think it is extremely dangerous um we
are lucky in england in the uk that we
don't lose
many people in fires
in wildfires however um they're becoming
so severe and i think fire rescue
services are so stretched
uh we've been really lucky this year in
as much as we've had severe fire we've
had severe water shortage but it hasn't
been coupled with extremely strong wind
that third factor could mean that we end
up with more experience of as we did in
say wellington in the east of london
where i think it was 14 hours in in that
row
burned the ground from a wildfire on the
edge of london i mean
it is incredible so it is dangerous
interestingly stuart gillian i bring you
in dorset and wiltshire fire service you
were shaking your head do you not agree
with andy dark
no i wasn't shaking my head jerry it um
no i agree with andy the the risks
around wildfires uh are increasingly
naturally going to increase with this
extreme about of
dry weather that we're having the ground
is is tinder dry and so
there are significant risks
however appropriately resourced we are
able to deal with that risk what would
you say to people um
for you and your colleagues on the
ground we're out to protect as many
people as we can what can the british
public steward do to help your
colleagues and you
well we're asking that the public to to
be responsible when they're enjoying the
outdoors you know we have
beautiful counties beautiful coastlines
beautiful inland sites across the uk and
we're asking people when they're
enjoying the countryside
to enjoy that in a responsible fashion
and we we were advocates of not using
disposable barbecues don't have open
fires or or campfires
because very very quickly in these
conditions a small fire can be out of
control
and lead to a significant wildfire
incident
and we've had a significant incident in
may of 2020 at ware and forest in dorset
where we had an area equivalent to the
size of 230 football pitches that
was a light and debt we had to deal with
for a number of weeks
and that incident was caused by um a
campfire left unattended
in the on the edge of the forest with
the high winds as andy just mentioned we
had all three of the uh the sort of
attributes for a significant you know
the perfect stormford incident with the
high winds and you heard me we asked
people to enjoy our countryside
responsibility quite right and you would
expect and hope people would do that i
don't believe in a nanny state i think
people should take responsibility andy
you saw me saying the introduction that
you know we're used to this in southern
europe in california and australia
is the fire service equipped for these
wildfires do they have the resources do
they have the equipment excuse me do
they have the experience to deal with
these issues certainly the experience
certainly the commitment um i think one
thing that is missing um
that we are that we are noticing we are
noticing is that uh the fire service has
been cut by 20 over the last 12 years
it's a fact uh at a time when it
probably should have been building we
should really uh crew and results our
fire rescue services for the worst
reasonable it's got to be reasonable
tonight the worst reasonable scenario uh
and not just the everyday trickle
shall we call it and we're not um we
really do need to have more firefighters
on the ground to basically get a heavy
weight of attack early to extinguish the
fire not allow it to develop you know
these fires develop and grow
you you would expect me to ask this
question why aren't there more
firefighters
um
public service cuts i mean there's
no other excuse or reason for it uh i
think it is a real mistake i think it's
not economic efficiency is that
attendance times that you know two fires
of all kinds not just wildfires now
are getting longer it does mean that
we're intervening it takes us longer to
intervene extinguish the fire that's
more damage more businesses as homes
damaged it it does mean that you know
people you know injuries and deaths that
could be reduced even further than they
we have been doing
um you know there could be a better
experience there
but in terms of the um the fire service
in relative terms is really cheap it
really is it's very efficient
um
but in terms of the economic loss in
terms of people's lives in terms of
their jobs and businesses it really is a
false economy to cut the service in a
way it has been cut i agree with that
stuart gillian i'll just bring you back
in um
i never understand the united kingdom we
seem to have the wettest winters ever
right we seem to have salination power
has been anything about we seem to pump
water into the north sea one of the
biggest things that we're told with
these droughts coming in the south and
then perhaps further north is that we're
going to run out of water is that a
concern for firefighters on the ground
that actually we will run out of water
what can you say to people watching
tonight thinking good lord that could
happen as well
um i i wouldn't say that we would we
would run out of water what would say is
that we would we we plan for these
events we work closely with our local
authority partners across dawson
wiltshire and we plan for events such as
these and we we enact those plans by
looking at the risks and of the
significant wildfire warnings and the
fire severity in indexes has risen the
alert has gone up to a red
this afternoon and we have had
subsequent meetings following that
information um i've been in the service
27 years and
water supply issues have never occurred
in in my service
we have a number of avenues we can go
down in terms of locating water supplies
natural water sources obviously the
dorset coastline provides us with a an
abundant water supply but we also have
options to use air support in larger
scale incidents so um i'd like to
provide that the public with the
reassurance that um we know where to get
the water from and we don't suffer from
uh inadequate water supplies okay
i understand i understand you you're
absolutely saying to people don't panic
because you don't want to scare me just
very quickly does it not annoy you
sometimes that people don't take
responsibility very simply from the fire
service you would hope i think that
people do the right thing would that be
a fair question
absolutely fair question we ask people
we've all got a responsibility to look
after ourselves and our environment that
we live in the devastation caused by
wildfires wherever they are in the uk is
huge it's huge to human life it's huge
to the environment and to the natural
habitats
and these wildfires take years to
recover from
so we all have a responsibility
we we we advise you bring a picnic don't
bring a barbecue
brilliant listen stuart gillian in poole
and uh andy dark 25 years experience and
now in the union thank you both thank
you for the job that you do and i
absolutely agree it's not a nanny state
but we have to take responsibility you
don't go into a forest with a barbecue
be responsible we have to help ourselves
help the people who are trying to help
us right next on uncensored it's
apparently sizzling out there although
i've been stuck in this office all day
and it's about to get pretty hot because
despite the aircon on tonight's jesus
journos the legend that is mike graham
and ava santina they're next we're
coming right back don't go anywhere
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to uncensored my friends
it's time for jesus journals piers is
pack his butt the yesterday thing
tonight i'm joined by talk tv legend and
my presenting guru mike graham and
political journalist who's been on
holiday ava santina hello team hello uh
let's start with the heatwave you saw
the uh the fire engines there uh the the
people in the the fire station's talking
about and it is quite serious we're told
tinderbox britain is about to go up in
flames this weekend and you and i agree
we don't want a nanny state but people
have got to be responsible mike haven't
they well yeah i mean who wants to have
a barbecue
on a burned-out piece of meadow you know
in the middle of this kind of heatwave
take some take some sandwiches you know
take a nice cold bottle of wine but
equally you know people get very
hysterical i was looking at this fire in
essex today right it was 87 square
meters that is about the equivalent of
the size of two um penalty areas on a
football pitch they talked about fire
fighters you know dashing out and
putting uh pulling this inferno out it
took them an hour you know it's two uh
penalty areas it's not huge it was about
ten firefighters and two fire engines
you know we're not talking about you
know malibu burning to the ground in
sort of 24 hours it's really i think the
papers really exaggerate some of this
stuff when they don't need to ava um
it's quite interesting because both of
those firefighters were saying we're
down on numbers and we can't he almost
implied actually they weren't trained
correctly for these wildfires what would
you say you blame johnson wouldn't you i
wouldn't
i mean
well i don't know i mean where is he
probably his fault but i'm gonna
sympathize and you're not gonna like
this he was told he couldn't get
involved so what's he supposed to do
it's not his fault they're taking
another he stayed on as a caretaker
prime minister so he should be around he
should be getting on you know getting
he's only staying on because they told
him
as he should that is his job and that's
why we are paying him as taxpayers is to
govern and help the country but look to
your point i understand what you're
talking about it was a small area but
the potential for that small area is to
become an entire field and to become
malibu it's totally not normal that
grass in england is is on fire at the
moment and the fact that you've got liz
trust about 10 minutes ago saying that
she still thinks that solar panels are
unsightly and she's not that interested
in green energy is absolutely insane and
let's come to the leadership debate i i
frankly i said last night introduction
it feels like it's been about 70 years
it is ludicrous we are a rudderless
country run by a government who are
nowhere to be seen today there was an
energy meeting apparently nothing was
agreed
and i did earlier i did where's
kierstama we did a missing person
right i mean party worked out after
demanding to see every tory minister
back at work but then realized oh
actually kissed arms away as well so
they can't
i have had some information by the way
it's been spotted in new york oh great
okay well i mean listen
just to go back for a moment to the
firefighters argument you know in spain
and in france and in portugal and all
those other european countries they have
massive numbers of volunteer firemen who
can come out bombardo as they call them
and they come out whenever there's a
problem and britain is not on fire you
know there are parts of britain that are
still very green yeah huge portions of
scotland uh where you know it rains
pretty much every day i was once in in
glasgow in june it rained for 26 days
you know yes there is a problem people
need to be sensible but let's not get
hysterical people getting hysterical
about everything britain isn't burning
you know just don't throw matches onto
it onto a brown side just don't do it
well it does have the potential to burn
and we've also we're out of water i
don't know if you saw the oxfordshire
town today that is completely out of
water you haven't even got anything to
put out anymore
situation we lived on an island
surrounded by the sea how are you going
to get that into the middle of the
country well if i was running the
government or the water company i'd
figure a way of getting a hose into the
sea and put it into that and can i also
point out
to everybody here i found out the other
day we lose 90 trillion liters of water
every day through leakage that's the
joke ava i want to talk about this
because it's close to your heart and
actually you might be surprised by our
reaction harassment go
which bit of it the part that i was
harassed i mean even on the way here
actually but yesterday i had a really
awful incident outside tottenham hill
station and unfortunately the british
transport police couldn't do anything
about it
and
well it's too rude actually to say but
it was very physical and it was quite
carnal actually that that will give you
a little hint about what was said but
you know i was told to ring the met
police and report it there i know that
the cps have come out yesterday and
they've outlined you know that we should
be reporting these and we should be
going further with sexual harassment but
at the end of the day like do you really
want to be bothering the police with
this like do they have enough time like
i don't know obviously that is a very
specific case and and personal to you
and we will try and do whatever we can
to support you can i talk about wolf
whistling because cat you know that this
is such
a an emotional subject as
women of all ages are saying that the
men wolf whistle at them and they feel
offended and it's fundamentally wrong
that would be your rightful opinion yes
but well i think that the two are the
same i think it's all harassment i think
it's quite feral that a man would want
to wolf whistle at you when you're
walking down the street i mean what kind
of person can't control themselves that
they have to learn and physically shout
at a woman that's quite obscene in my
opinion mike yeah i think she's right i
mean i can't imagine why anyone would
want to do it i've got a daughter um you
know when she was younger she's about 14
or 15 we were in new york quite a lot
people would be leering out of calm
windows at her because you know she was
14 she was quite a good looking young
woman and i was appalled by that and
i've never ever in my life ever dreamed
of wolf whistling anyway
i'm going to add a caviar and i've got
two sons who would never do it either
i've got two sons i wouldn't
let's just talk and if they did
slap i'd do more than that my sons would
never do that to a woman and my respect
to you for talking about it very quickly
nhs diversity male online has found five
adverts for senior equality roles at
trusts across england which pay up to
seventy six thousand pounds a year am i
wrong or should we perhaps not be
spending that on dentists
doctors nurses whatever do you not think
it gets worse than that because not only
have they got the diversity cred they've
got the net zero crowd they've got
sustainability officers getting paid 120
000 in almost every health care trust in
this country ridiculous but we need that
you need them in the nhs because for
some reason this country is still stuck
in quite you know quite racist ways look
there was a program we all watched it
adamkay's fabulousness is going to her
in the first scene of that show there
was a racist incident a patient launched
at a black woman that is the the case
for a lot of things up and down the
country i think there's diversity
officers in there i i think i would
probably answer that in this way and
it's the same way that i answered the
climate i know there's a situation in
terms of climates i know there's a
situation still in terms of of
harassment and the need to try and
understand more the problem is we've
only got one minute people in this
country all over this country cannot pay
their bills they cannot put pets in the
car they can't take their kids to school
they cannot do anything and right now i
want to say that there is surely a
reason for saying that's a little bit
more important right now you would want
surely out of that money
15 more nurses because i would right now
i don't think that you can compare it
like that i don't think that you should
scrimp on diversity or like you know
offering something that's not racist
just because you can provide an extra
nurse also we don't even have nurses
that want to come and work in the nhs at
the moment so the staffing isn't even
there like you know regardless of
funding i think you're both great final
word michael graham well the thing about
racism is that there will always be
racists you will not cure racism by
having diversity officers the people who
are racist are always going to be racist
until they die and when they die they
won't be racist anymore it's as simple
as that um i love you too together thank
you for sharing your story and i meant
what i said i hope you get the support
you deserve we'll see you tomorrow are
you not working tomorrow i'm doing the
show after you oh we're on breakfast
tomorrow morning lucky lucky people uh
that's it from me thank you for santino
thank you mike graham thank you for
another week back tomorrow at 8 o'clock
by the way whatever you do tonight
whatever you do this weekend appears
told me to say it keep it uncensored uh
we're back tomorrow later have a great
night
[Music]
join me ian collins every day on talk tv
there is nothing we hate more than
hypocrisy discussing the big issues why
was it so hard to establish the deputy
leader was at a meeting with her
colleagues the callers alan in grimsby
tracy in burton on trent dave thank you
very much picking apart the beast this
simply does not wash look who's back
under the spotlight
this is talk tv news
good evening i'm emily rose adams an
official drought is expected to be
declared for parts of the country when
the national drought group meets
tomorrow and as temperatures climb the
risk of wildfires in the uk has been
raised to the highest level
labors criticized the prime minister and
the chancellor for failing to come up
with measures during crisis talks today
to help families pay energy bills boris
johnson did say he urged the sector to
ease pressures new forecasts suggest
that average gas and electricity bills
could soon hit 5 000 pounds a year
and more than 30 people have been
injured after two roller coaster trains
collided at legoland in germany two
people are said to be seriously hurt in
the incident reports suggest two trains
hit each other on the park's fire dragon
ride that's all for now we'll have more
after the talk
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign